hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash
[Music]
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons welcome
to the Tim Dylan show everybody this is
Tim Dylan we're joined as always or
usually by the great David Costa it's up
to thank you for coming to San Diego
where I am having a great weekend here
at American comedy company in San Diego
a city of very attractive if a little
bit [ __ ] people they are very
attractive and the shows have been
excellent people have been coming out
and we're having a lot of fun and
actually they're not that stupid I mean
they're probably stupid but not in the
club they've been getting all the jokes
and you know I mean I'm I'm I'm pumped
about that thank God I had a friend and
I was like you know some of the people
you know San Diego's not the brightest
city you know and my friends like you
know working out being healthy that's so
also it's a different kind of
intelligence and I'm like I know that
dummy what I'm saying is that that
doesn't help me if I'm making [ __ ]
jokes what reference is that people
don't understand right that's the
problem I'm not saying that [ __ ]
following you know a rigid keto diet
isn't some evidence of intelligence and
reason I get that okay I'm with you
all right I'm not taking away all their
[ __ ] accomplishments I get that
discipline requires some level of mental
dexterity I'm with you I'm saying that
if I make a joke about something and you
stare at me like you're brain dead I
don't care how good you look it doesn't
really help have you did you when you
were doing stand-up did you ever come
down here yeah yeah a lot it's kind of
the place to go for stage time in LA and
how did you find it I didn't like it why
did you not like it there
you like what you're saying they're kind
of dumb people you got a you got a they
want crowd work and like talk about how
drunk people are right that type of [ __ ]
kind of a daft crowd but there's
something nice about the city here
because they don't I haven't seen any of
these pseudo-intellectual pretend
artists I know that is nice yeah they
don't have any of that it's [ __ ]
military athletic people you know they
got the life here they're not trying to
worry about any nonsense yeah you know
some real bar fights here people beating
each other's brains out just [ __ ]
like animals way and I say it on stage
this is the way to experience the
Apocalypse hot on a beach
[ __ ] yep cuz New York and places like
New York and LA they're all gonna be
trying to solve the problem you know
they're gonna die saying actually I'm
right like that'll be the last words
they say right they'll be like no
actually and then you know it'll all end
but here in San Diego the last thing
you'll hear is like calming and yeah
people in San Diego look like they [ __ ]
with their tongues out oh yeah like
extreme people there's some really
attractive people yeah very hot I went
down to seal Cove the other day which is
a beach where they've where there's a
lot of seals and sea lions and the
tourists Americans go visit the sea
lions to feel better about their own
weight which i think is very nice of San
Diego to have a place where Americans
can walk out on the beach and go see I'm
not that fat look at that eighteen
hundred pound sea lion the sea lions are
of course usually much better-looking
than the Americans because they carry
their weight better
that's just a fact that's a reality
there's a lot of fat you know how fat
people are when you're down on the beach
and and next in a 2,000 pound sea lion
they look fine you know what I mean they
look like I'm like what animal could I
put next to you that would dwarf you and
select we need a hippopotamus
we need a rhinoceros like is it 2000
see line these people aren't scared at
all they're walking up to these things
you know smacking him in the face what
up [ __ ]
you know ease it on their backs riding
them around
I'm kidding they're not doing any of
that but supposedly at night I was
talking to some guy drunk high school
girls from La Jolla run down to the
beach or college girls or whatever and
they just like cradle the sea lions real
hammer I got me our baby mm-hmm I love
you and then every now and then a seal
of c-line takes a bite out of their arm
yeah all for an Instagram picture yeah
awesome selfie over self I like you said
at breakfast she said uh you said what
was it there first
what did you say how did you phrase it
uh there there first
there first what was it I don't know I
don't even remember things I say I don't
know it was about the sea lions and
though this is why it doesn't talk more
people say to me like why doesn't he
talk more I'm like he does kinda has
Alzheimer's he said no it was like their
first lesson they learned was the sea
lion biting them oh right said it in a
very funny way well God yeah okay all
right
it's not me those two like me you know
what you're gonna have you I'm gonna
build your fan base but he said
something very funny you pray that is
the curse of some people say something
very funny and then if cameras go on or
recording devices go on they completely
do not have it anymore there are people
that I've seen kill on shows and then
they'll go to a festival like jfl or
they'll do Conan or something and then
as soon as it matters not that this
matters but as soon as like anything
matters they're just there like they
just walk out and they just have nothing
and hmm and they fail and they and they
in they leave no they don't leave if
they stay but they never quite get it I
will say iiiii I had to end a friendship
recently with somebody who I could see
was going insane it's very important to
spot people on their journey to insanity
and then throw them out of your life
before they officially arrived in the
insane asylum and you could see them you
could see it
happening to a lot of people there's a
lot of like different indications that
give one of the indication was a friend
of mine recently telling me that they
needed a sit-in assistant but they
didn't have a job they had no job they'd
spend all day doing nothing but they
need an assistant that's like that's one
of those [ __ ] indications that
somebody's about to lose their [ __ ]
mind and they had to go and then they
asked about Ben who produces the show
they're like is Ben your assistant will
Bend schedule like furniture deliveries
your ham like what furniture who's
having furniture delivered you don't
have a job you're not doing it like
these people aren't doing anything and
you realize oh they're starting to lose
touch with reality they're like it's
like you know how you dip your toe in
the pool they're dipping their toe in
outer space and they're seeing how it
feels without gravity and they like it
they're like oh it feels nice without
gravity and so in order to do that you
need to assemble a group of people
around you that won't question any of
these things ago you do need an
assistant you need a team really really
you need a team and they're like you're
right I need a team but unfortunately
this person had to go and it is it is
unfortunate
iiiiii try to surround myself with rich
people but a lot of the problem is if
they're very if they're there's nothing
worse than a rich person who hasn't
accepted their rich mm-hmm and then
tries to be smart this is this is of the
archetypes of human being that
absolutely need to be caught in a
Riptide
you know it is this is one of the
archetypes a person who's guilty about
their amount of privilege that they have
money so what they then have tried to do
is become like an artist or become
intelligent and every interaction they
have with the world is just this
insufferable need to feel smart and to
be recognized for their intelligence but
they also like shoes like it's that type
of person they're like I'm a genius but
I also love sneakers that's a new
archetype of human being by the way
they're like I love revolution
I'm a rare you know I'm uh I'm a real
I'm a thinker and I realized society's
[ __ ] but I also love sneakers and that
I have those two parts of my personality
that are constantly you know I love
jackets and fashion and also you know
I'm a genius you know it's just both of
those things that you get ya and it's
utterly so I had to get have you ever
torched a friendship and then not
regretted that you're not friends with
the person but regretted the way that
you did it
mmhmm yeah yeah we're impulsive like say
something real you know like a head shot
I mean you feel kind of bad about it but
you you're probably on your way to not
being friends anyway I felt bad that I
said a few things that I should not have
said but I think sometimes in this
society honesty is is people recognize
honesty as an attack especially when it
is worded like an attack but but I do
think that people you know to be an
honest person is I hate to say it but it
is kind of revolutionary in in a city
like Los Angeles where many of the
people you're dealing with are mentally
ill they're insane so for you to say
something that's based in reality throws
them you know for loop and then they're
angry you they're mad at you they're mad
if you suggest something that's reality
based right if you suggest a solution
that's based in you know any type of
reason or you know I mean people just
look at you like you're a dick they're
like that guy sucks you know that guy's
a bad person because he chose to
puncture you know this little bubble of
insanity that I've built that I cannot
have punctured I just have to hmm but I
didn't feel bad as I said a few things
that I regret and I think that's what
happens unfortunately when you let stuff
build up you know I think that's what
happened with OJ I think it's what
happened with a lot of people that
should have addressed those issues
earlier and did it but why is OJ the
most well-adjusted person
on Twitter why is he looks good plays
golf seems happy has pretty decent stuff
to say about the Democratic debates has
pretty good analysis why is that because
he can't and he did you know he's in a
wild life yeah think about oh geez life
and think about Donald Trump's life
right these guys have had wild lives Oh
Jay was was star running back movie star
hmm maybe murderer
got away with murder he was like the
toast of LA Society got away with murder
ended up going jail for like stealing
what did he do he stole his memorabilia
back from a guy that was selling his
memorabilia now he's out he's in you
know the golden years of his life he's
playing golf he looks good he's you know
he's free he's got nothing to hide and
if he's free he's got nothing to hide I
mean all in all let's be honest is it a
bad life let's be honest look at OJ's
Simpsons life he's experienced
everything he's really experienced
everything everything that you the highs
the lows you know he cut off someone's
head almost he near he nearly
decapitated somebody that he did not
like that he was angry at many of us
when you're angry what do you do you
gotta shove it deep down because you
don't want to get fired some [ __ ] walks
in the [ __ ] Starbucks or wherever
you're working starts being demanding
and you want to throw hot coffee in her
face you want to scold her you want to
just see her you know collapse like the
Witch and The Wizard of Oz I'm melting
I'm melting but she's not melting she's
burning because you threw coffee on her
and she's got at least second-degree
burns on her face and she's screaming
and her child is there but her child
isn't crying because the child is
actually also kind of happy that the
mother got it the child is kind of has
that quizzical look on its face like is
this justice I'm witnessing is this my
first this is my first experience with
divine justice this guy that just threw
hot coffee and my [ __ ] mother's face
but you can't
that right so you stuff it down and then
you drink smoke you do whatever people
you know eat unhealthy and you stuff it
down you stuff it down you stuff it down
Oh Jay walked in he saw something going
on mm-hmm that he was not a fan of and
he made the choice to not stuff it down
he made the choice to take action and
listen I don't know Nicole Brown Simpson
I did not know her I did not know Ron
Goldman I was a child and I lived in New
York and I I do not condone murder I
want to say that because I think a lot
of people listening right now are
confused and that's fine because life is
confusing I think many people are
starting to realize that that these
absolutes you're not really serving us
to be honest and I think we need to
start reexamining these situations
mm-hmm but what OJ did probably felt
really good in the moment right you know
it probably felt really good in the
moment to cut off their heads yeah
now immediately after he probably was
like well that was a lot yeah yeah let's
do mouths a little bad you know but and
then then you know you start thinking
about self-preservation and but what I'm
saying is let's just look at the life
let's not focus in on any part of his
life
let's just let's let's focus out and go
what a life when he's on his deathbed he
could say I've done it all I got away
with murder I was a movie star I was the
toast of the town mm-hmm I mean he's a
remarkable figure I got to be honest
with you I don't want to use the word
hero because it is and don't stop with
the violence against women [ __ ] he
killed a guy too
don't start with me with this he killed
a woman what about Ron Goldman yeah yoga
Donald Trump crazy life millions and
millions and millions of dollars
the
the apex of a certain type of society he
was never like on the inner sanctum of
New York society but close enough he was
that new 80s you know uh you know
billionaire mega you know you know a
business magnet that courted Fame you
know like a wrestling he'll I think on
the Miss Universe pageant was at Miss
Universe yeah right mm-hmm I think Miss
Universe own multiple casinos ah I mean
a truly extraordinary life and again the
pret and now the President of the United
States this isn't good or bad we're not
more I'm not looking at the morals of
any of these situations I'm just zooming
out and I'm going compared to the
experiences that most people have on
earth okay mm-hmm if you were to have a
museum of great lives not I mean great
in the sense of like they dedicated
their lives to making the world a better
place but just great lives like where
you look at their life go oh [ __ ] that's
awesome Donald Trump OJ Simpson people
like cardi B who was a [ __ ] stripper
was drugging people in Miami some [ __ ]
guy that looked like me in a hotel room
exactly like this waking up going where
the [ __ ] my [ __ ] gold card
you know I'm cardi B was [ __ ] cutting
lines with a putter pool mm-hmm and now
you know she's you know has had the
number one song I mean these are wild
lives Jeffrey Epstein Jeffrey Epps
you wanna talk about a life let's talk
about a life for a minute ok-ran and in
national sex trafficking ring a minor
for chill you know not for children for
children with children he ran an
international pedophile ring sex
trafficking ring and he had some of the
most fit wealthy you know famous and
wealthy people
the guy had multiple residences multiple
properties had connections had access
maybe worked for the CIA or the Mossad
nobody knows I will I will say this
about Epstein though what I will say is
like all you idiots that are like oh
yeah we worked for the Mossad yeah it's
very possible he were to the Mossad but
are you telling me and you know the
observer wrote some article about this
where they're like well you know I bet
it's you know CIA wouldn't tolerate this
he's Brees working he was a spy but we
don't know what you know who he was
spying for we don't know who he was so
you're telling me you're telling me
ditch every I've seen is compromising
high-level US politicians people from
all over the world he's working with the
Mossad and the CIA has no [ __ ] clue a
bunch of fat guys in Ohio with Wi-Fi who
can get on reddit seem to have a pretty
good idea but the Central Intelligence
Agency has just got no [ __ ] idea of
what Jeffrey Epstein is doing how stupid
do you have to be to believe that you
know anything to let this country off
the hook anything any logical job these
people will jump through [ __ ] hoops
to just let this country off the hook
and go well no is this is not is not our
intelligence people our intelligence
people are saving us from bad guys all
over the world they're not participating
in this they wouldn't dare I mean but
that's the thing man I I wasn't what I
said it was unfortunate you gotta move
on you gotta get rid of friends she
gotta get rid of close friends you have
to cancel your friends and family it's
so easy to cancel a stranger so many
people are like oh let's cancel this
celebrity you know
let's how about about no cancel your
father how about that okay you want to
be a tough guy cancel someone you love
and you care about but you realized
you're not loving and serving you mm-hmm
that's what you need you need people in
your life that love you but are also
willing to serve you do you think I'm
wrong about that no no I mean it's it's
funny to just say out loud you know I
don't know why it's funny to say out
loud I think because people a lot of
people believe truly that they are worth
nothing and they're correct and those
people are you know people aren't they
have a slave mentality you know uh that
that's why like I believe we should all
have health insurance but the reason I
don't get on board with socialism is
because like I look at people out there
and I go I don't really want to be
associated with a lot of them I feel
like a lot of them shouldn't be here but
they are and I don't mean in America I
mean on earth and I just I believe we
should all have health insurance I think
we should all have some kind of social
safety net but I don't I don't like
collectivism I don't embrace
collectivism because I feel like many of
the people on the planet simply
shouldn't be there accidents they're
their biological accidents that are here
they're breathing and they're taking up
space and they're consuming resources
but what are they generate they're not
generating anything you know and then
people say oh that's inhuman blah blah
blah uh
go scratch you know it just we need to
go back to the times of
radical individualism where the way I
feel radical individualism is a concept
where you would radically be an
individual and it would if you are
really being an individual you won't
have a lot of friends your social circle
will shrink if you start doing and
saying the things you want don't worry
you will not get invited to places if
you just put it out there now the more
and more you keep it in and you bottle
it in the more and more people are gonna
have you come because they want you to
sit around and back oh [ __ ] you got
angry huh but if you go out there and
you you you say things like you know why
can't I [ __ ] my cousin or you say things
like you know I I don't I don't know why
but there's something comforting about
Oh Jay there's something in his eyes
that feels at peace if you say that it
makes company OJ's eyes or it Pete when
you look at him he feels like as you
peace if you say things like that the
invitations are gonna dry out don't
worry about it don't worry about it you
don't have to go along with everyone's
horseshit find somebody to [ __ ] get a
pat have a friend or two and then move
the [ __ ] on enough enough wood cocktails
after work nobody needs that sitting
around with a bunch of people get out
get away leave society and I think I
believe this is a message that many
people don't because everything is
collective now everything's based on
like and but nobody really feels that
way everybody's pretending to care about
other people but nobody really does in
their life because they all go on
Twitter and talk about how important it
is that everybody has health care but
then they their parents were rotting and
some you know some home or they haven't
called their brother in eight months or
they don't really give a [ __ ] about
their nephews or nieces or they're
barely good to the people that live in
the you know live in their surrounding
area their neighbors they just they
don't care
they put on this idea that they give a
[ __ ] about other people no I think it is
very empowering and liberating to get
out there and say I believe that we
shouldn't be [ __ ] by these large
corporations we should have you know
kids should have food you know they
should not a lot of it
not too much ministry right amount you
give a you give him a nutritious meal
they'd still be hunting here's something
with all these kids that are hungry if
you gave them a nutritious meal they'd
still be hungry like if you gave a kid
vegetables in a meat they would still go
to bed hungry with a headache like I do
because they don't they didn't get to
have alcohol cupcake the size of a
basketball because that's what they're
all used to a lot of these kids are just
used to eat and [ __ ] fun dip and you
know ketchup milkshakes and then
remember Michelle Obama Michelle Obama
tried to get these kids eat healthy
there was a literal riot there was a
riot cuz she's like how about you eat
healthy and then because kids start
going insane because food and addiction
sugar which a lot of people in this
country have I have it if I don't of
sugar and this is what I'm trying to cut
it out but I get headaches I start
getting angry people irrationally
actually getting angry people that I
haven't seen and forever I just I start
wishing horrible things happen to them
ending friendships yes but I also like
I'll lay in bed sometimes and I'll
imagine someone getting killed I'll
imagine all the different ways that
someone could die and it's all and then
I'll have a slice of flourless chocolate
cake and I'll go guys not a bad guy
really it's not that bad of a guy
but I will spend an inordinate amount of
time imagining them dying and and and
and being like yeah that's good because
I think when you when you detox from
sugar and you start working out I did
the treadmill the other day
you gotta up your levels of compassion
because when you're a fat slob it's very
easy to just have compassion because
you're like I'm a fat slob and everyone
else is a fat slob and I don't care and
I don't require anything but
you're an insane fit person and you care
about yourself you walk around the world
and sometimes you look at people that
aren't caring about themselves and I
don't mean necessarily only in looks but
I mean like well in anyway
and you just get angry at them and
you're like these people don't have the
level of discipline that I have and it's
very and it makes you angry you know
that's why a lot of people are those
people that are in shape or like dicks
because they're because they're right
that you know I mean it just is what it
is it's like so you got to do something
that opens up your [ __ ] you know
ability to be compassionate mm-hmm you
don't really do anything to stay in
shape not really in shape you just and I
just take long walks it's kind of a
misleading around I don't do anything
like on purpose you ever see yourself as
like a fit guy like getting in the gym
building it up I just I hate changing
out of clothes to go get sweaty and then
have to take a shower get back in
regular clothes and all that I hate it
yeah I mean it is it it is it is a whole
lifestyle that you have to like you do
have to really just go wholeheartedly
into you have to get addicted to it you
got to get addicted yeah you have to
make it where it's like I feel terrible
if I don't run five miles it's true man
and a lot of people do like a lot of
people you know if they don't exercise
they feel like they they haven't changed
your clothes they haven't showered they
feel like they haven't brushed their
teeth they feel incomplete you know I
want to be one of those people I want to
feel like that I want to have that
relationship with my body you know I
feel like once I lose weight I'll get
cancer I feel like that like once once
in my body once I lose weight I'll
immediately get cancer because my body
won't know like what's going on this is
that powerful sugar is sometimes like
sugar we'll say in my own head it'll go
I'm the only thing keeping you alive and
I'll believe it I'll be like you're
probably right like sugar will go if you
get rid of me you're dead you're not
gonna exist anymore that's how tough it
is man it's tough to change behavior
it's one of the hardest things in the
world to do to change your behavior you
know it's very tough and that's what
people don't
succeed at what they want to do is
because you're unable to just say to
themselves I have to change and in order
and once I change I gotta kick all these
people in my life out that haven't
changed and that's unfortunate you know
but you got I mean you got to do it's
like when you're a drug addict and you
get sober you don't go to a crack house
you imagine that imagine a sober guy
still hanging out of the crack house
just looks nice it's got new clothes
feels good
you just shows up to the crack house
like hey guys what are you doing they're
like words with smoking a rock that's
what we do and you sit on the couch like
I remember that and you're still trying
to talk to them as they [ __ ] they're
all cracked out twitching yeah you know
you're blending the money mm-hmm you're
drinking milk just trying to talk about
the weather glass of milk you're like
you guys want to go to a movie likewise
no we want to smoke more crack you don't
want to go to a movie we don't want to
change
you've changed I'll get the [ __ ] out of
here stop showing us what it's like on
the other side that's a thing kicked
them out the people that aren't changing
with you you know folks we've talked
about [ __ ] how important it is
because you really got a [ __ ] your way
into a better echelon of society most of
you are not gonna be able to do that
with your own wits or Talent
[ __ ] your way in there I'm telling you
okay and you got to use blue chew
because blue chew is great if you like
sex you'll love blue chew it offers men
a performance enhancement for the
bedroom wouldn't you like to last longer
and go extra rounds okay [ __ ] your way
up tribbles can work faster than pills
that's what blue chew is it's a chewable
with the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis you could take it on a
fuller an empty stomach
online physician consultation is free
cheaper than those other two Viagra and
Cialis okay takes a few minutes to
connect with a Bluetooth comm affiliated
physician if you qualify you get
prescribed online quickly they want this
in your mouth they want you chewing this
blue okay
gives you confidence in bed every time
you and your partner will love it you
gotta chew it and do it
I'm telling you most of you you know
some of you out there have nightmare
lives and the way to have a better life
is to [ __ ] your way into sand for a lot
of you you're not [ __ ] your way into
[ __ ] the Rothschilds but maybe you
just [ __ ] your way into somebody that
has a has a house you know 20 minutes
outside of Cleveland you know I mean
that's what most of you're gonna get but
who gives a [ __ ] you throw the dick to a
girl to inherit you know she inherited a
little shitty house maybe a little
shitty uh barn in upstate New York you
can live in that who gives a [ __ ] it
doesn't matter folks just sling that
dick with confidence you don't know who
you'll end up with some chick whose
grandmother's about to [ __ ] stroke
out and leave her a Mitsubishi Galant
you and her could live in it and smoke
glass I don't know it's different for
everybody but if you don't [ __ ] her good
you ain't getting that [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
your way into something we got a great
deal blue cheese calm get your first
order free when you use promo code TD
just pay $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code tt easy
goodbye I mean I don't know what to say
Marianne Williamson man she's hip to all
this [ __ ] she dad said she [ __ ] gets
it man
Marianne Williamson is fun to watch
because I like I like the archetype of
woman that she is is somebody that I've
met over and over again in my life it's
the mom who lets you smoke pot in her
house yeah but she'll also corner you
and tell you about a ghost that she
dated for a summer you know it's the mom
that'll talk about her spirit guides you
know while she sells you weed that's the
mom yeah she just gets [ __ ] up and
when she's having a good day she's
talking about spirits and you know but
when she's having a bad day man she's
just spitting and cursing Marion
Williams too when she's having a bad day
is just walking around a beach screaming
at seagulls
screaming of birds because that's the
other side of spirituality people don't
realize that but once you really open
and you're letting everything in and
you're having the full range of human
experiences once you really start to do
that there's also some real darkness
that comes along with that as there
should be and you know we haven't seen
that out of Marianne Williamson but I
would certainly like to I'd love to I
would love to see her just smoke and
crack you know she is interesting though
she seems like if she was president and
like mercury wasn't retrograde she'd
give everybody like paid vacation time
yeah you know yeah like we all get the
month off she'd have an astrology based
foreign policy exactly good for her man
I'm with it I'm with rich white [ __ ]
talking nonsense and I've always been
with that it's fun they're fun to be
around hi it's fun to be around people
that have never set foot on planet Earth
it is so fun to be around people that
have never set foot on planet Earth they
have no [ __ ] idea of what they're
talking about
yeah it was a great Woody Allen movie
called everybody says I love you and
it's a musical and Goldie Hawn plays
this you know Upper East Side Park
Avenue liberal or Upper West Side
wherever they live they live in this you
know very wealthy area in Manhattan and
she does there's this great scene where
she's giving a speech to the NYPD and
she's like these prisoners need to
design their own cells with European
decorators you know and she goes into
this whole thing and then they invite a
guy that just gets out of prison to
their house for a dinner party and it
just eats great I'm not saying that
Marianne Williamson is wrong about a lot
of [ __ ] I bet she's right about a lot
you know she's talking about dark
psychic forces and everything like that
sure but this mannequin sense of good
and evil that we need to shove
everything into is terribly childish you
know this is like Lord of the Rings
stuff this isn't a rational way to
approach the problems that we have by
her being like there's the dark psychic
force coming from the red states and the
blues
it's need to harness the power of the
crystal it's like no [ __ ] what we need
to do is figure out what to do with the
sixty percent of the workforce it's
gonna be [ __ ] irrelevant very soon
these problems are larger than just the
reactions to them okay it's not just
about psychic forces and good and evil
it's not the neverending story this is a
a comp there's complex issues that where
the answers are not inherently political
I don't believe that I believe the
answers are going to be maybe they're
gonna come out in the tech space or
they're gonna come with new technology
or they're gonna come with you know I
don't believe that somebody in
Washington is gonna be like well I
figured it out because if you look at
all the advancements and all the things
that have changed your life a lot of
them have been not political they've
been technological they've been you know
cultural so I understand what Williamson
is saying she's like let's not focus on
these policy wonks she said in the
debate you know cuz Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren are very you know
committed to plans and proposals which
is all necessary and when what marianne
williamson is saying is like hey man
it's about more than that she's right
but it's not about is drawing a line
around a group of people and saying
they're a dark psychic force it's just
not helpful it's not helpful Mary Ann
you know I know you're trying to do she
was like the racism and the bigotry this
is a drunk white chick at a party whose
husband goes haven't you had enough and
she's like no the racism and the bigotry
she goes I was a dancer how was the
dancers the girl when I danced people
said I was like a bird on the stage they
go Mary Ann Mary Ann honey why don't you
eat something and she goes I'm not
hungry there's so much racism and
bigotry there's the dark psychic force
coming and we need to fight it with the
energy in the water I keep telling my
husband about the energy
you know and he's got a he's got a look
at his daughter and go let see your
mother's it's psychopath you know she
loves you but she's mentally ill and and
Mary would that's why you know the
Millennials lover and younger people
love her cuz she's a lot of fun that's
why we like Trump cuz he's fun people
that have real ideas to solving our
problems now we don't even pay attention
to them
yes we're like oh okay
we kind of just want because it's an
acceptance of and I'm not gonna I'm just
gonna spend a minute on this folks talk
because I know people get upset but it's
an acceptance if we know we're at the
end now we know that whatever's coming
next will not be human right we're good
whatever's coming next will be post you
mean this is the last dance of humanity
so we're just bringing in the characters
send in the clowns you know and I'm all
for that
this is the last stand that we're making
let's have fun let's have it be
entertaining right however will I hope
she wins I hope she wins and there's a
seance in the Oval Office and
everybody's got Harry Potter wands and
roll waving them at each other who gives
a [ __ ] we're in too deep math is not
getting us out of this potentially who
cares yeah I'm all for our man I love
that archetype of person a white
privileged woman who's full of [ __ ] I've
gotten a lot of great drugs from these
women they have the best pills they got
good [ __ ] drugs and they care about
everybody except they don't want anyone
in their yard or home you know hi these
racism and bigotry two poached eggs
please Josephina two poached eggs make
sure they're properly poached this time
I don't have to hit you again the racism
and the Biggers rear she was talking
about Flynn did she was talking about
the other place I forget where she lives
she's like what happened in Flint would
not have happened in my neighborhood
which is true and tragic but it was just
funny just this recognition you know
right what
happen in Flint we need to change things
I'm like we do we absolutely do and
Flint is a [ __ ] disaster
but I'm all for it man bring her on yeah
is it helpful that she's says you know
half of the country's demons probably
not but who gives a [ __ ]
that's that Hillary deplorable thing
yeah I mean Trump's the president do
whatever you have to do to get get rid
of him I think there's there's something
to what she's saying is this his madaky
in sense of good and evil everybody
wants to be fighting a war I don't know
why everybody now can't find meaning and
anything except combat that's an
interesting thing to think about why
can't anyone find any meaning unless
it's combative unless you're beating
someone else it's not about you it's not
about individualism that's we talked
about before it's not about you know you
do you know only you only the only
person you're fighting is yourself
you know you got to beat the record that
you say it's none of that it's none of
that we've destroyed that everything's
about we've got to combat something
there's some outside influence that we
need to find every part of life is not
political which is what leads you to
totalitarianism by the way because if
everything is political what then
happens is you have this you know
population of people that's completely
incapable of seeing anything outside of
the lens of politics and then you lead
yourself pretty quickly to a situation
where you have a the state you know with
his boot on your neck and everything
whether it's art or everything in the
public sphere
everything is message driven they're all
political messages and it's [ __ ]
creepy man it becomes North Korea it's
like nobody wants to live in that you
look at every movie review every album
everything everybody's trying to inject
politics into everything people don't
know where this goes you don't know
where it leads
you know yeah I think it just leads to a
place where the public sphere
it's just polluted with these empty
political messages that's
you know that's okay because I'll just
be smoking crack at Marion Williams and
OJ why are these people in our lives
why is OJ Simpson in our lives is he
here to teach us something seriously
it's a fad he's a fascinating person I
want to get him on the show and I know a
lot of people will be mad at me but the
people that'll be mad at me for having
him on the show will be people that are
mad that he killed a woman they don't
care about Ron Goldman they don't give a
[ __ ] if he only killed Ron Goldman he'd
have a show right now on vh1 okay but
because he killed his wife
all the female comics did that have kind
of yelled at me for tweeting about him
yeah be angry that he's on the show no
one cares about the Jewish man yeah damn
right yeah I'll tell you this folks
everybody in Edinboro right now bombing
good for you I'm a big supporter of
people taking their horrible acts and
inflicting them on another country I'm a
huge supporter of that and spending an
inordinate amount of money to bomb for
30 days straight in the Scottish
Highlands good for you they don't cover
any of the expenses not to go not when
you're a loser and I'm not talking to
establish people that are you know
killing it over there I'm talking to you
know the people that think it's a good
idea because they've been bombing in New
York and LA they think maybe it's a good
idea to go perform on the moor and
Scotland that's gonna change everything
no it ain't no one ain't okay had enough
British comedy is different you know
they have a one-man show they want a
story arc it's not just stand up they
want an arc they wanted to say something
beginning middle and an end they wanted
to have you know infrastructure like a
show I one of the best clubs they ever
performed and was to stand in Glasgow
Scotland because it's a theatre comedy
there has its basis in theatre comedy in
America has its basis in circuses
depression-era tent carnivals and then
eventually Mafia owned lounges a
nightclub stand-up comedy was kind of
invented by the Mafia you know just
another thing to put in in the
while people were drinking so America is
more rough-and-tumble the jokes are
shorter it's in and out Britain you get
more space and there's long periods
without laughter and people are really
into that you know which I kind of
appreciate to an extent I like the way
that we do it here personally but I can
appreciate the way that they do it there
too and when you go to the stand and
Glasgow
there's no drink service in the room so
that the host will come on for 20
minutes then you go up and you do 20
hosts will come back on and do another
15 20 and then somebody else comes up
house will come back on and then if
you're headlining you'll go up but the
shows like two hours long and there's 50
intermissions after each act people go
drink at the bar then they come back to
their full attention is on you know I'm
in San Diego and I'm performing last
night and I hear people going like why
does that have cranberry in it is that
cranberry and I'm like hey I'm up here
trying to do something can you shut up
but that's you know we're in the United
States so I'm kind of a fan of the idea
of you go get hammered and then just sit
the [ __ ] down with your drinks and watch
this yeah I like the you know there's
something really I like about that and
there's something interesting about it
but it would just feel like a freedom
being taken away from Americans though
if they were if that was to happen here
we'll be like upset by that
yeah people have panic attacks if the
waiter who doesn't come to their table
mm-hmm because people need to know that
a chicken finger will be delivered to
their mouth unless they'll have a panic
attack they won't be able to concentrate
if their blood Sugar's dropping they
want to know that they can get a chicken
finger in their mouth and they need to
get some booze you know mm-hmm it all
goes back man rugged individualism fuel
I mean I some people that listen to this
show I'm so proud of the way they live
their lives I sometimes I follow them
back on Instagram and I see them and
they've only got a few pictures up and
she's them and their cat or them in the
woods with a gun and I say I'm so proud
of them I'm so proud that they've
accepted that life is solitary and that
they really should
be accountable only to themselves and
I'm very proud of them sometimes people
that follow me have these large groups
of friends and their rows going on
vacation and I see through that I know
what it is
stop it be like the man with three
photos one of animated cat and one of
him in the woods with a gun and the
quote I'm ready I don't know what he's
ready for but he says I'm ready it's
probably I don't know you know but that
you know just a nice quote that says I'm
ready to dive in the woods with a gun
he's just waiting
[Laughter]
wax wax wax wax [ __ ] get a website
losers with a wick so you can start from
scratch choose over 500 stunning
templates that's the most innovative
drag-and-drop website builder so you can
easily customize your site and add text
images videos whatever you want you can
even build your site using Wix ad I
artificial design intelligence a few
simple questions
oh that's all you need you can answer
them and then you and your business and
Wix will create a stunning website for
you know you or your business or who the
questions are about you will not create
the website the robot alien AI will
create the website you just sit on your
fat ass and put all the work into the
business okay we built Tim Dylan's going
to hell calm using Wix it was so easy to
do t IM dylan TI ll ons going to hell
calm and if the producers that I work
with built it it's easy because they are
brain dead crack addicts so if those
people were able to build a website let
me tell you right now you will too so if
you have business or content you want to
promote you need a professional website
okay if anyone that I everyone that I've
worked with in this business has been
dumber than the last person I've worked
with in this business okay if I had
anybody that could support me in the way
that I needed to be I'd be Kevin [ __ ]
heart but the reason I'm not is because
I'm literally always dealing with
Mongoloids literal [ __ ] and I know
you're not supposed to say that anymore
but that's [ __ ] what these people are
they are dead eyed retards that look
like they're on a steady diet of paint
chip
in Flint water and they [ __ ] barely
make sounds they bark like a sea lion
and they're on drugs and the drugs are
the only thing to keep them kind of
saying you know because their minds are
melted they're stupid people okay
they're pointless cretins nobody uses
that word enough cretins they're
carnival barkers okay they're dog people
not in like they like dogs like they are
dogs they're dumber than dogs all the
people in the business that I've worked
with you know so if they could build a
site using Wix you can too and if you
click the link at the bottom of Tim
Dylan's going to Alcon di ll ons going
Telecom wilkes will give you 10% off any
premium plan and by the way I messaged
all you [ __ ] that I said will you
like to come on you know none of you
message me about promoting your [ __ ] on
Wix I'm about promoting your [ __ ] on the
show you you know I guess you lost
interest in it that's totally fine but
or you didn't lose interest in it
whatever it was I'm telling you right
now you got your premium plans upgraded
I said I was gonna give you three
minutes I still will give you three
minutes if you contact me we'll set it
up but I know one of you or one of you
guys feel like a band you're on tour
listen I don't give a [ __ ] so you know
figure it out okay
Wix Wix you anyone can build a website
using Wix even people that should
legally not have a business even they
did they refill bad not did they give me
another rice krispies treat in that
little little thing well now okay go to
way
folks cut this [ __ ] we're in like the
weird calm before the storm you know
because there's not gonna be a storm
there is no war you know the world will
end in a very like it'll just be long
and drawn-out mmm things will just get
worse and worse and worse little by
little Trump gets elected to get
anything he starts a war mmm it's hard
to say if he starts a war or not I mean
John Bolton's in there really trying to
push Iran the Nyoka the neo cons never
really gave up path they're just morph
and by the way neocon neoliberal it's
all the same thing it's just war
profiteers that's who they are
so when Bush left office they grabbed
John Brennan and they grabbed you know
people that were influential in the CIA
had people that were influential in the
Defense Department and they pushed you
know what they always push eternal
conflict okay and and then Obama's out
and our Trump's in so they start sending
in people and they have Kushner's here
because Kushner is probably a little bit
more sympathetic to some of their causes
to trump so and he just maybe I guess
you know somewhat more agreeable than
Trump as a personality so they're
they're kind of going into vodka going
at Jared and you know John Bolton is in
there there are people in there that are
just want more war and more war and that
seems to be and again a lot of it is
these are people whose bottom line is
you know affected greatly by
how much conflict there is on this
planet mm-hmm so the more that there is
the more money that they make and so in
order to justify that in their own heads
and I've spoke to some of these people
they tend to believe that without
America inserting itself into every
problem the world would be much worse
off and that's where they all go to
sleep at night by saying we're the
American Empire these people don't have
the self-awareness like you'd almost
imagine that they'd be like yucking it
up like I can't believe it we got
ourselves in another war like
that's not the way they believe they
actually believed very much in after the
fall of the Soviet Union they believed
that America being the only superpower
has a responsibility to impose you know
you know law on the rest of the planet
and but that law what that law really is
is protecting American trade routes and
protecting future American markets for
American goods and services and
protecting multinational corporations
you know we're not talking about law
like freedom of speech and freedom of
association in the rule of law and
things like that that are all you know
positive to try to introduce into a
society we're not talking about that
we're talking about the ability of
American businesses and multinational
corporations to do whatever the [ __ ]
they want which is why they all hate
these countries that don't allow that
rush you could North Korea and obviously
both Korea contemptible state Russia
there's a lot of [ __ ] up things but
the reason that we like Saudi Arabia for
example there are pals they come for the
barbecue there's Prince Bandar eatin Q
with the bushes this pork is so tender
they are lobbing the heads off of gay
people over there they're chopping off
hands they're beating women with sticks
we don't care and their leaders come
over here to have a hoedown they're
having a hoedown
with the bushes but we looking flat amir
putin like he's Voldemort and the reason
for that is because we're eatin with
saudi arabia we're making money with
them it is what it is folks I'm tired of
explaining you should know that it
doesn't mean you have to hate America I
love America America is a great country
we did we did we've done some fucked-up
[ __ ] but I don't think America is the
CIA I think America's you know these
retards in San Diego that all bought
tickets to come see my show they're
eating guacamole and watching seals [ __ ]
you know I think America is my producer
Ben you know good-looking but brain-dead
person who literally walks around
doesn't know where he is half the time
you know he's good-looking and stupid
he's they're a better combination to be
by the way that
what San Diego is good-looking stupid
people have it all yeah okay because
they don't know what they don't know and
everything you know being good-looking
you're connected with your body like oh
here's my big dick and yeah I'm
good-looking and blah blah blah and you
don't have to really think too deeply
about anything else because that gets in
the way you know really does I mean
we're very excited to do an episode
coming up at the end of August where
we're gonna teach kids in school how to
be popular because many kids are not
popular in school and they're there
they're there for going in and shooting
these schools up or they're there you
know going even worse joining an improv
troupe or something so what we're going
to try to do is we're gonna try to
basically put together a you know just a
little checklist for kids that are in
high school or college too more so high
school college doesn't really matter
high school matters everything you'd be
in life will be decided in high school
college really doesn't matter I mean
this is another lie that's like all the
losers in high school become really cool
people in cop you know that's not the
way it works losers in high school
for the most part stay loses their
entire lives and the people that aren't
losers in high school like oh yeah but
how's your bully doing now he's the CEO
of a fortune 500 company okay but why do
we get these but but it's because you
know everything's written by the Nerds
and the losers yeah yeah so they write
all these things where it's like oh the
ugly girl gets hot and you know joins
the Peace Corps and falls in love with a
gun shut up doesn't [ __ ] happen you
know so we're gonna teach people when
it's about being an individual and I
spent not giving a [ __ ] about people and
I don't mean not giving a [ __ ] about
people I mean not caring what people
think about you but you got but you also
do have to care what they think about
it's very interesting I'm gonna go I'm
gonna give a lot of advice it sounds
like double-talk
but that's cuz you're too stupid to
understand it okay you kids out there
because it's all about caring and not
caring and if you don't even know what
that is well then you need to listen in
the episode were you popular in high
school
yeah I was a decent owner right the
answer and you don't and there's nothing
wrong with that I made a great journey
I was unpopular ninth grade I started to
come out of my shell in 10th grade 11th
grade I started
you know feeling myself at twelfth grade
I was nominated for homecoming king and
I was one of the most popular people
that had ever attended Holy Trinity
dialysis in high school it Hicksville
Long Island New York right where Billy
Joel wrote that song the village green
it's right about where I went to high
school remember those days hanging out
by the Village Green yeah we do because
they were phenomenal and then when I
learned I learned a lot of lessons about
popularity and that number one it's the
most important thing on earth okay it is
more important than honor character love
is the most important thing having other
people like he was literally everything
if everyone hates you you could be the
most honorable person in the world
wouldn't you die history is just gonna
say that you were a pedophile and that
you beat your wife because everyone
hated you so don't be a dick don't be a
dick when things going bad a lot of
people when things are going bad in
their career they're a dick and then
when I'm sorry but these going good in
their career they were decadent when
things turn around they start to go bad
then they're like well you know I just
I'm really grateful and I really love
everyone as I love the community and
it's like we didn't really feel that way
when you were doing well then it didn't
go the way you thought it was gonna go
and now you're back even everybody hugs
everybody sees through that so don't be
one of those people if you're gonna be a
dick be a dick or I respect people that
are pieces of [ __ ] the whole way through
yeah things are good things are bad
they're dicks some of my favorite people
in the world have tortured me in and out
mercilessly okay they're dicks things
went well they were dicks my one of my
old bosses where I love things were good
he was a dick you did well he was a dick
he did bad he was a dick he was always a
dick okay and you got used to that
because he wouldn't give you an inch
I respect people like that what I don't
respect is people who like you know
turning on turn on the nice when they're
you know flailing around barely able to
survive their heads above water barely
they're drowning except their mouth can
stick out in the ocean and they can take
brats and go woohoo and then apparently
then somebody swims next to them and
then they're nice then they're nice hey
is there room in your raft but when
they're doing well and they're cutting
through the water and their swing
and they got it if somebody comes near
them like get the [ __ ] away from me
be like that all the time you know yeah
you know I mean that's the reality I'm
nice to people all the time I care about
people I do see that why are you letting
I'm nice to people
I'm very nice to people you are you are
I'm not a dick to people I just don't
what I don't see here's what I get you
this is why people think I'm not nice I
don't tolerate people's mental illness
like I won't like if somebody's telling
me they're doing something and they're
not doing it I'll be like I don't I
don't find that to be the case like I
had somebody the other day which took me
out to dinner goes well not took me out
but we were having dinner and they go do
you think I'm on the right track in
comedy and I went no no so now that's a
dick thing right that's dick in but I
view it as being actually nice to the
person because they're not on the right
track and if I was telling them that
they were on the right track that would
me be me kind of then the identified
years when nothing's worked out that
person should have the right to come
back to me and hit me with a bat they
should be able to be like well you told
me I was on the right track right
those are you're honest with the person
I'm like no you don't have really
anything going on social media wise
you're not really trying you don't have
a pod get like all the ways that people
are finding people you're not doing any
of that [ __ ] hmm you got to do that and
but it's jarring for him to hear because
his face like he didn't expect that
answer he expected me because everyone
else is like him and you know you're not
doing anything somebody's gotta tell you
that people have to tell you reality
you're being nice by saving him time
basically he asked me I wouldn't go up
to and tell him that out of nowhere
although I have probably I'm sure have
but I wouldn't tell him if he didn't ask
me because I've been told that people
told me you're not as good as you think
you are you got away this opportunity
you think you want you don't want to
wait you got to wait it's never nice
thing to hear it's always a hard thing
to hear but if you cannot hear hard [ __ ]
you
not gonna get anywhere people's
inability to take criticism is one of
the reasons that they don't progress
because you need to be able to just kind
of swallow it take the criticism and go
okay yeah I agree with some of that I
don't agree with it but just the
exercise and like taking the feedback
taking the rejection taking whatever it
is and then going okay I'm good over to
the next level is what it it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're always
gonna be right about it you're gonna
take a lot of criticism that's not valid
if you're trying to get somewhere and
that's okay too
you know let's talk about Monday comm
many of you out there are running a
business and you know a lot of those
businesses just consist of you selling
HGH in an Applebee's parking lot but
some of them require a bit more planning
and for those of you who are having
trouble and need business managerial
tools we have Monday comm because
there's always gonna be a Monday folks
okay you got to go in and attack the
week you have a good Monday you might
have a good week and Monday comm allows
you to do all of the things that you
wouldn't necessarily be able to do on
your own okay it takes no sock no time
to set up you can easily customize it
okay instead of all the random email
spreadsheets files whiteboards to-do
lists all that [ __ ] Monday comm is
suitable for any size team from a couple
of freelancers to thousands of people
communal communicating and collaborating
across the globe
so check out Monday comm it's an amazing
team management tool I still don't know
I mean I've been reading this ad now for
a few minutes I still don't know what
this is I still don't have any clue I
imagine
I mean I don't know but I imagine it's
some to do I have to know what something
is if I advertise it who cares does it
matter
it's a tool that you need it's a
software and what it allows you to do is
collaborate and to communicate and it
facilitates a lot of what's going on out
there cuz there's a lot of problems in
the corporate space there's a lot of
waste there's a lot of unnecessary
mumbo-jumbo people running there you
know flapping their gums running their
mouth there's a lot you got to go
paperless there's a lot of paper post-it
notes you know you got a home office a
bunch of post-it notes and where's the
cat who knows buried under paper got an
old you know fax machine with somebody's
sweater on it hasn't been used in eight
years you know you got a tingling in
your hand you don't know if it's a mess
or not the point is this you got to go
to Monday calm it streamlines it all it
allows you to be a real businessman
you're gonna be a big man or woman
you're gonna be a big man or woman and
you have a business you have a business
maybe it's not in an office maybe it's a
you know in your house you have a
business and you you go in that room in
the back and you got that bottle of
liquor you think nobody knows about but
everybody smells it on your breath you
go in that back room and you ever just a
little glass of warmth just to keep it
going and then you get on Monday calm
and you do business because you bring
home the bacon the family depends on you
and you got software you're not you're
not in this alone you're fighting a good
fight so what you pushed your wife she
got in your face you didn't hit her you
were just pushing her away from you in
the kitchen she started screaming in
your face because she's always doubted
you and she's never supported you at the
right time that's why you need Monday
calm it
allow you to seamlessly organize all of
the disparate elements of your business
and make them into one function your son
does not speak to you okay he fears you
he looks at you with a mixture of fear
and disgust and he goes up to his room
looking at God only knows what on the
internet you hope one day you don't get
a call that you know he's been
apprehended after you know shooting up a
big sporting goods you don't know but
you wish you wish you and the boy could
have more quality time but you can't
because you're sitting in your back room
masturbating the torture porn and doing
business cuz you're business man you
gotta go to Monday calm folk / Tim
Monday calm / Tim okay because when
you're out with your buddies and your
your golf in or you're just throwing a
few drinks back at the club you know
you're at the Country Club and all those
other guys that work for institutional
banks cuz they're suckers and you went
out on your own to day trade and they
thought you were mentally ill but now
you've established you were at the
forefront of something very real and
that these brick-and-mortar offices are
going away soon we'll all just be
working in little pods from our offals
but it'll be okay because we'll have
Monday comm cuz you're a business man
that's what you are you tell all your
buddies at work at Bank of America
corporate and Charlotte a couple of guys
you went to college with it you're doing
just fine sitting in your back room
drunk watching the market you feel the
pulse of the market go through your body
okay Lisa hope it is you hope it's not
ALS but you don't know you played some
sports you don't know what's coming and
if you do get a death sentence like that
it would be freeing because you could
just finally go and do all the drugs
that you really want to [ __ ] do that
you miss God you miss those drugs but
you can't do
you're a businessman businessman I'm a
bigger man Monday dot-com / Tim I do not
know what this product is I do not know
that I do not know but I'm telling you
right now if you don't have it you're
gonna [ __ ] fail
I just want smoke crack with Marianne
Williamson you know the confidence of a
white girl on cocaine in the suburbs is
like nothing you've ever seen a white
chick driving around on a Honda Civic a
white Honda Civic coked out of her bird
smoking Newports on her cellphone the
confidence level mm-hmm
you know also a very a very high
archetype of person that people are
realized fat girl with a very clean car
this is an archetype of person a lot of
fat girls cannot stop shoving food in it
they can they have lost control of their
own body they cannot stop eating so they
make sure that their environments are
immaculate they're very clean right and
I've had many of these friends the fat
girl with the very clean car that's a
total thing their car is so immaculately
clean it's like it was never food in it
it was like it doesn't smell like food
but you know that there had to be food
you look at the girl and she's pouring
out of the front seat and you go there's
been food why doesn't it smell like
french fries every now and then you
would get my car and you'd see a little
perfectly diced tomato that fell off a
Mexican pizza
just a little diced tomato sitting there
on the dashboard but you will never see
that with the fat girl with a very clean
car you will smell beautiful perfumes it
will be very nice she'll have maybe
track lighting when you sit down they'll
be a pleasant aroma even as the car
pulls up you'll be like wow her hair
will be neatly back her hair will be
neatly back scrunched up in a ponytail
she'll always have new clothes on you'll
get in the car you'll
even if it's a shitty little car it'll
be so beautiful and immaculate and
you'll be looking around because you'll
you'll look at the girl and you'll
expect it there'd be like a a bucket of
fried chicken in the back you know but
no maybe maybe some gum but only in a
compartment where gum should be right
okay hey fat girls never show you
themselves eating ever but there's
there's a lot of this is a specific type
of fat girl this isn't a normal fat girl
this is the fat girl with a clean car
this is a mythological beast that does
exist who drives around Long Island
drives around New Jersey she always
gives everyone rides mm-hmm she's always
has that car she'll pick you up and drop
you off she doesn't feel that connected
to you she feels like she's in her own
world she's driving around she's always
got a hot friend he's like hi hey and
that hot friend's a mess and not that
hot friend is another archetype the hot
girl with the disgusting car right very
hot girl but there's you know empty
bottles of perfume and vials a crack in
the backseat and dogs and cats and you
know monopoly pieces and you know it's
just a mess she's got a prom dress and
25 pairs of shoes but not the fat girl
not the fat girl with a clean car that
girl at the end of the night she drops
you off in your house you give her a
quick kiss she says thanks good to see
you she's always funny
she's always personable but not
overboard not so much there's a type of
fat girl that's always you know pining
for approval this is not that girl this
is the fat girl with a clean car it's a
it's a it's a this is the got a really
dance on the head of the pin here this
is a very specific type of human being
hmm and if you
experience with the factor on the clean
car you'll never forget it you'll never
forget how fat she was or how clean that
car was because both of them are amazing
and she had an interesting type of fat
it was a hard fat it wasn't sure latinus
like funnest fat to play with like a
lava lamp that was constantly
rearranging itself it was a hard shell
fat like someone had poured magic shell
it was like one of those desserts never
spent Instagram a dessert you hit with a
spoon and then it opens up and then goo
pours out yeah chocolate goo that's was
the body type of the fat girl with a
clean car just a big hard shell and he
knew inside there was goodness there was
whipped cream or chocolate ganache but
you couldn't tell you couldn't smell any
food you never saw any food and she just
picked you up dropped you off sometimes
she didn't even look like she was having
fun she barely spoke she barely spoke
she would go to the beach with all the
other hot girls and stand there and
every now and then you would say
something to her and then she would say
something back to you like yeah really
that's really oh she said she'd go yeah
really and then you get back in a
beautiful car that is a person that I
miss and a person I don't know if I'll
ever see again because we've taken fat
and made it into this mainstream thing
and we've made everybody feel good about
their bodies well I mean that's good for
people I guess but what happens what
happens to the fat girl with the clean
car what happens to that very distinct
very specific human being who said very
little and just drove a clean car does
that person disappear do they go extinct
I don't know that's something I wanted
to discuss iced and Marian whoops oh let
me explain this I am in a bed in a hotel
and we tried to do the podcast upstairs
they have like a pool and everything but
the problem is there's a wedding going
on at 5:00
they have to do some work we're here the
Andaz in San Francisco shred out to the
Andaz San Diego San Diego right I'm
sorry San Diego Tim de la comédie calm
for all your needs for all your needs I
got a lot of cool dates coming up just
go to the website check it out and put
them all up on Instagram good nights
North Carolina August 22nd to the 24th
I'm back east for some shows in the fall
Tim Jay Dylan D I ll win on Instagram
and Twitter davon what's going on
youtube.com slash Devon Casa de VA n
have a podcast on iTunes hate the 11
with Devin Costa and Twitter at Devin
Costa you know folks I don't know what
to tell you you know you're like Willy
Wonka's grandfather right now Uncle Joe
he's the best person in that [ __ ] I
watched that movie suck by the way now
that was kind of fun I liked Willie why
no I mean it was good I liked Willie
Wonka but I didn't like the message it
sent and the message it sent was that
everything's about luck it's not okay
everything's not about luck the golden
ticket the Charlie happened to get yeah
cuz why grandpa grandpa Joe's like we're
gonna go down there and you're gonna get
one then what happened they didn't want
to let Charlie in right why didn't they
want to let him in do you remember Ben I
think he was late is late it was
something like that I mean grandpa Joe
pushed his way in I think grandpa Joe
only gets up to go inside when he comes
back home with the golden ticket right
isn't there the moment where he finally
gets up to go I don't somebody make
somebody gets Charlie in that Factory
[Laughter]
candy is so dumb - that's the other
thing
candy stupid you know I want to do Willy
Wonka a Timmy Timmy Timmy in the ice
cream factory where at the end and he
gives the whole factory to Charlie again
Charlie doesn't know anything about
running a factory he's white trash from
Britain okay you think he's gonna do a
good job you think he knows about
margins on chocolate you [ __ ] goofy
freak no sell it to a corporation you
built a [ __ ] brand you could get some
real money don't leave it on the [ __ ]
table giving it some kid and now I'm
Charlie I'm running the factory now shut
up
gives people this idea that everything's
about luck it's not about luck it's
about dealing whatever you can get away
with folks if you see somebody hit him
with a stick keep on going that's what
it's all about you know I mean I would
for the person who got out and said do
what you can get away with cheat on your
taxes cheat on your wife you live once
why is Jason I just want to go back to
this why would i look in OJ's eyes do I
see the piece of luck just a beautiful
lake pot I mean does anyone else feel
this and it's confused by it is he
innocent somebody hugged me at my show
the other day they're like I like the
you did a Michael Jackson joke but you
know he innocent like yeah I'm with you
I'm with you combine this ticket you
know he innocent you know when somebody
says that you know what I want to save
them I'm gonna look right at them and
whisper in their ear hey don't tell
anybody
so is Hitler he said wouldn't it be good
if she was like yeah I know I know
goodbye